la première ministre la réforme des
retraites que nous allons finaliser
cette semaine après des mois de
concertation et de travail est à nos
yeux essentiels et nécessaires
il s'agit ni plus ni moins que de sauver
notre régime par répartition quasiment
unique au monde pour la solidarité qu'il
crée entre les générations
sans cette réforme les 1,5 cotisants
pour un retraité en 2035 ne suffiront
plus pour pérenniser le système la
baisse attendue du pouvoir d'achat des
retraités sera inacceptable le défi site
cumulé laissez à nos enfants sera de
plus de 150 milliards alors oui la
réforme que nous portons est avant tout
une réforme de responsabilité vis-à-vis
des retraités d'aujourd'hui et des
jeunes générations qui n'ont pas apporté
la charge des inconsciences passées en
outre elle était allée dans le temps
pour être plus acceptable madame la
Première ministre nous devons aussi
c'est notre rôle rassurer les Français
oui nous leur demandons de travailler
plus longtemps mais nous devons aussi
leur donner des garanties c'est ce que
nous souhaitons entendre aujourd'hui
ainsi qu'en est-il des mesures pour ceux
qui ont commencé à travailler tôt la
prise en compte de la pén de la
pénibilité des pénibilités devrais-je
dire est-elle garantie en particulier
pour les carrières
la situation des femmes est-elle enfin
améliorée après toutes ces réformes
qu'ils ont ignorées vont-elles être
enfin rétablies dans leurs droits à
savoir une retraite digne vous savez à
quel point le groupe démocrate qui a
travaillé enfin allons-nous améliorer le
taux d'emploi des seigneurs dans deux
tiers ne travaillaient plus pour mettre
ainsi un terme à se gâchis humain tous
ces points madame première ministre sont
l'assurance du respect de notre contrat
social je vous remercie